GOOGLE MAPS:
I’m sure you’ve all used Google Maps.
Whether it’s to get directions to a new restaurant
or stalk someone’s house through street view,
we’re all familiar with the tremendous resource
that is Google Maps. Ssomething that most of us
likely take for granted is that just like all
of Google’s other products, Maps is completely
free to use for as long as you want. This sort of
freemium model isn’t too surprising with search or
email where everything you need is virtual, but
maps is a pretty grueling business that requires
a lot of physical resources. From the dozens of
satellites and hundreds of street view cars that
constantly monitor and take pictures of the
Earth to all the servers and supercomputers
required to complete millions hours of processing
to seamlessly stitch together petabytes of data.
And let’s not forget about all the hours spent
on blurring out license plates, faces, houses,
and other personally identifiable information.
Clearly, there’s no question that Google Maps
takes a lot of resources to keep functional and
up to date. And while its value proposition to
Google wasn’t too clear in the early days, Maps
has grown to be one of Google’s most lucrative
businesses. In fact, Morgan Stanley estimates
that Google Maps will pull in over $11 billion
in revenue in 2023 alone. For perspective,
that’s about the same as TikTok. And if we
valued Google Maps the same way as Alphabet,
Google Maps itself would be worth roughly
$62 billion. That’s about the same as Mercedes
Benz and more than Volkswagen and PayPal. Heck,
that’s enough to be a top 250 company by itself.
But how does Google even monetize Maps? They don’t
show video ads or search ads, and there doesn’t
seem to be much opportunity to collect and sell
our data based on just our Google Maps usage.
Well, it turns out that Google has come up with
some pretty creative ways to indirectly monetize
Maps while staying surprisingly ethical. So,
here’s the insane rise of Google Maps
and how Google Maps makes so much money.
AN UNDERWHELMING START:
Taking a look back, the story of Google
Maps takes as back 20 years to 2003. Like many
of Google’s products, Maps wasn’t something that
Google created in house, it was actually something
that they bought from 4 men named Lars Rasmussen,
Jens Rasmussen, Noel Gordon, and Stephen Ma.
Together, they had founded a startup called
Where 2 Technologies in Sydney Australia. The
idea for the platform was pretty simple: create
a desktop map program. But it turns out that this
was a lot easier said than down and pretty soon,
they needed a lot more resources leading them
to meet up with Google in late 2004. Initially,
Google wasn’t actually convinced about Where 2
Technologies until the founders suggested the
idea of converting the desktop application into
a web platform that could be accessed much more
easily. With that, Google would agree to take a
flier on the company for an undisclosed amount
which was likely well below $50 million. Where
2 Technologies wasn’t the only map based company
that Google purchased in 2004 though. Around
the same time, they would purchase two other
map companies called Keyhole and ZipDash.
Like Where 2 Technologies, Keyhole was a
desktop application unlike Where 2 Technologies,
Keyhole was more focused on the macro scale. Aka,
viewing the earth and various countries as opposed
to specific streets and directions. I don’t think
you’d be surprised to hear that this is what would
turn into Google Earth, and Google got this entire
company for just $35 million. But, in terms of
value, nothing comes close to ZipDash. In fact,
ZipDash might be Google’s most bang for
the buck acqusition of all time as they
were able to purchase the company for just $2
million. What did ZipDash do you ask? Well,
they specialized in using location data from
mobile phones to create approximate real time
traffic data. This tech would be underappreciated
and under used by Google for several years,
but once smartphones started taking off, all
of that would completely change. But anyway,
going back to 2004, after all the acquisitions
were done, Google would spend a few months
refining the technologies before finally launching
Google Maps on February 18, 2005. Apparently,
Google Maps would get Slashdotted the night before
its launch. If you also don’t what that means,
it basically means that Google Maps went viral
on a forum the day before launch which led to
an explosive launch right out the gate but this
traffic didn’t last. You see, for a lot of us,
myself included, 2005 probably sounds like
the stone ages when it comes to the internet,
but it turns out that there were already
some pretty great mapping solutions on the
market before Google Maps specifically Yahoo
Maps and MapQuest. And while Google Maps was
superior to these offerings from day one, that
by itself was by no means enough displace the
market leaders. For most people, Yahoo Maps and
MapQuest already accomplished what they needed,
and they had no reason to use Google Maps instead.
So, the general consensus for year 1 was that
Google Maps did just okay. It pulled in a decent
amount of traffic but nothing too crazy. Google
could’ve easily just called it here and kept Maps
a small side business, but they were determined
to make Maps much more than just that. And as
such, they would scrap everything and start over.
A COMPLETE DO OVER:
Given the underwhelming response,
Google would decide to do a complete rewrite of
Google Maps. In turns out that while Google Maps
was better than MapQuest and Yahoo Maps, for
modern standards, it was still rather slow,
so their number one goal with the rewrite was to
maximize speed and optimize the user experience.
After about an year, they would get the platform
to be nearly instantaneous, allowing them to make
much more ambitious moves starting with Satellite
view. Google would stitch together all of the
imagery that they got from the Keyhole acquisition
to create satellite view. Fun fact, satellite view
isn’t actually satellite view in most cases. It’s
actually arial view taken from low flying planes.
The Google team was actually debating on whether
to call it arial mode or satellite mode. But when
Sergey Brin made the decision to call it Bird
Mode, the rest of the team would decide to unite
and defy Sergey by just calling it Satellite Mode.
Apparently, Sergey would never comment on this
name change. But anyway, Satellite Mode would
come out in late 2005 and this was immediately
a selling feature for Google Maps. Putting the
actual utility Satellite Mode aside, most users
just liked messing around with it. Being able
to see your house and city from a birds eye
perspective was super neat. You kind of felt like
you were top secret spy or something. Google would
simply take this novelty to the next level in May
29, 2007 with the debut of Street View. Street
View was obviously an extremely ambitious project.
Google was basically signing up to bankroll cars
driving around every single street in the entire
world. It turned out to be really popular feature
though. Now, not only could you see your city from
an arial perspective, but you could literally walk
through it as if you were actually there. But
while satellite mode and street view definitely
made Google Maps unique and drove popularity, the
number one trend that made Google Maps ubiquitous
was of course smartphones. In fact, smartphone
based revenue accounts for nearly 90% of Google
Map’s revenue which is not that surprising.
Android is the most popular operating system
in the world used by billions of people. And you
know what comes preinstalled on Android devices?
It’s of course Google Maps. So, most Android users
are naturally just gonna use Google Maps whether
it’s the best or not just like how everyone used
to use Yahoo Maps and Mapquest. All of this has
allowed Google Maps to reach over 1 billion
monthly active users. But, while they were
eventually able to get to a dominant position,
it was by no means an easy road. While Google
was able to acquire the core 3 companies that
make up Google Maps for less than a $100 million,
actually making Google Maps successful cost a lot
more money. According to one professor, just the
upfront cars, cameras, computers, and manpower
alone cost over $400 million. And Google never
stopped updating their imagery. If anything, they
actually do it more and more often with time. So,
there’s no question that creating and maintaining
Google Maps has cost Google billions of dollars
over the years which brings us to the question of
the day: how did they make all of this worthwhile?
MONETIZATION:
Google’s monetization strategy when it
comes to Maps breaksdown into 2 main categories.
Given that Google is an advertising company at the
end of the day, I don’t think you’d be surprised
to hear that the first category is ads, but it’s
actually done in a really tasteful helpful
way. You know when you pan around Google Maps,
you see businesses like Walmart and Home Depot and
Starbucks? Well, listing a business or location
on Google Maps is actually completely free and
basically anyone can do it provided you have the
right documents and rights. If you wanna take this
to the next level though with custom branding and
high visibility, you can pay Google a fee and
basically make your listing a premium listing.
To be honest, this seems like a win win scenario.
Users are able to find businesses more easily with
their logos and companies are able to increase
their brand presence in a discrete non intrusive
way. But that’s only half the story. Google’s
other mode of monetization is honestly far more
interesting which is through APIs. You know how
when you go to the website of a restaurant or a
local bowling alley, you’ll sometimes see a small
map showing you the location of the avenue? Well,
companies are able to do this thanks to Google
APIs for which they have to pay. And that’s
more of a small use case. Imagine what happens
when someone like Fedex, Uber, AirBnB, Zillow,
or DoorDash implements Google Maps. All I can
say is that that would cost quite a bit of money,
and that’s just the most obvious implementation
of Google Maps API. Likely the most commonly
used Google Maps API actually has nothing
to do with Maps directly. You know how when
you start entering in a billing address or a
shipping address, the address autofills? Well,
that’s thanks to Google Places API. Basically
every company in the entire world who collects
address information uses Google Places or a direct
competitor like Microsoft’s Azure Maps. If they
don’t, they’re probably stuck in the 1990s. On
a per use basis, Google Places is relatively
cheap. It’s only about 3 cents per use but think
about how many times you yourself might use this
every year. Maybe 10 times? That itself is 30
cents worth of revenue for Google. If 3 billion
people were to do this every year, that itself
is $1 billion worth of revenue for Google from
just one API. I think you can start to see how
all of this can add up to $11 billion when you
throw in hundreds of different APIs and uses
cases. But even putting the financials aside,
thanks to Google Maps, Google has been able to
map out the entire globe in pinpoint detail. This
means knowing the exact address and location of
any and every commerical and residential property
in the entire world. And if that wasn’t enough,
they know the exact location of billions of people
on this highly detailed map at any given point
in time. If that isn’t an insane amount of power,
I don’t know what is. And that’s why even if
Google Maps never even made a single dime,
Google would be the real winner when it comes to
Google Maps. That fact that Google Maps pulls in
$11 billion in revenue on top of that is simply
a bonus. With historically high interest rates,
the appeal bills and bonds is the higher than
ever, yet traditional brokerages haven’t really
adapted with the times. They still expect people
to use clunky bond tables, scroll through long
overwhleming lists, and even use virtual keyboards
till recently. And that’s why we created our own
modern bond platform: Silo. At Silo, we prioritize
the user experience and the ease of finding and
investing in the issuers you know and trust,
so that you too can lock in high yields. Also,
choosing a strong user experience doesn’t
mean sacrificing on safety. Every Silo account
is insured by $500,000 in SIPC insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance. Also,
all funds deposited on the platform will
be maintained by our trusted custodian,
Interactive Brokers, who has experience managing
$373 billion worth of assets over the past 45
years. So, if you’re looking for a modern way
to invest in bonds, please consider checking
out Silo in the description below. Another
business that’s extremely powerful despite
its profitability is WhatsApp.
Check out this video to learn more.